vous pouvez me montrer tout ce qu'il
vous plaira vous Mollez vos genoux vos
épaules et vos bras vous pouvez sans
plusur exhibez vos appats vous montrez
nu du haut en bas je ne regarde pas car
je vous en informe votre corps si bien
fait si parfait dans ses formes ne me
fait pas d'effet quand on est vraiment
amoureux maladame on ne peut maladame on
ne peut non lesim qu'une quand on a
trouvé celle qu'on veut on n veut plus
qu'une rien qu'une pas de si c'est une
blonde aux yeux bleu madame on ne peut
madame on ne peut aimer les brunes et si
c'est une brune qui nous app plu toutes
les blondes du monde
plus vous pouvez me montrer dans un
mauvais dessin le dessin si joli de si
joli sain vos deux grains de beauté vos
trois petits vaccins j'ai la vertu d'un
capucin je suis plus sa qu'un sain vos
charmes vos avances ne peuvent t'exciter
soitd sans nance que ma
curiosité quand on est vraiment
amoureux madame on ne peut madame on ne
peut dans les M c quand on l' trouvé
celle qu'on veut on en veut plus qu'une
rien qu'une pas de si c'est une blonde
aux yeux bleu madame on ne peut madame
on ne peut aimer les brunes et si c'est
une brune qui nous a plu toutes les
blondes du monde ne compte
[Musique]
plus